here we go again against quattro
princess awesome that I hadn't had his
the sky recently oops ok so the
transposer to a regular regular scotch
four nights yeah recently a song game by
live on aronia and we're here where he
played with Bishop d6 in this kind of
situation oh maybe I can do and do this
first just trying to get a slightly more
interesting position then you normally
get with d5 which is really a bit boring
ok so hmm
hm even if I've is a move it is a move
takes takes rook takes Bishop h7 check
but I can take take check on d4 Queenie
five huh
right it looked really really fishy for
me and stature gives me the beetle porn
hmm I wonder okay if I check be too he
has a knight a form hmm i can go bishop
tea for the on bishop d45 this is
probably not a bad idea strategically
speaking covering the night centralizing
the bishop okay so i'm not sure if i
should go to e5 him
I'm not sure let's play a useful move
first now I have to taking be to I don't
know seems very risky to do that's just
I want to centralize IAM get good
position for my pieces is out for night
h5 very likely so maybe just move the
Queen yeah maybe but what is the Queen
doing them
not sure what my queen is doing on c8
now that I think of it maybe I can get
it to be for something where at least
I'm attacking stuff yeah yeah i was
thinking to steak but yeah f6 is pretty
serious and f6 maybe i can go f6 bishops
before I have t5 now it's definitely
dangerous for black very dangerous I can
still play Bishop c4 right a group to
seven which is this is really bad yeah
if he sees Bishop c4 I'm in big trouble
I probably am a big trouble anyway but
Bishop c4 is I think very problematic
okay also interesting
not so interesting d for esc five and
i'm not really sure what my replies to
that i really don't have one and maybe
this for Bishop e8 I mean I'm worse
clearly worse anyway but maybe i can i
can patch some some holes if i get the
bishop to f7 yeah i'm just doing
basically just playing a porn down here
Bishop c4 Bishop t6 try to hold on you
create yeah still it's still reasonably
reasonably stable maybe but certainly a
very bad position for me oops okay now
that's it's typical fancy but good move
that quite often this kind of thing is
working
stop do not take it but yeah okay if I
take it I'm just I'm just getting killed
so let's do this at least that I'm not
seeing a clear threat now for him i mean
at least i can take cake and cake on the
next move or something queen before it's
not doing much to be honest
Jim
it's probably a loss anyway I would like
to it is really really bad I only hope
is some kind of technical miracle
yeah and then he goes goes d6 if i go to
be six okay yeah poor if he makes a draw
I'm happy but it won't would be very
weird to go for a draw there with white
time morning yeah time warning i don't i
don't have a plan or whatever i'm just
just shuffling him just a miserable kind
of position
yeah some way too yeah come on let's
take this thing it just it just looks
terrible with what can you do
Bishop t3ss idea that's a good idea
not even the trick here I don't even
have any kind of thing here just totally
lost Queen g6 check check check check
that's good work everyone black resigns
well sure what a bad bad bad game f5
really looks like a bad idea looks like
a bad idea giving out all the dark
square dance and stuff but I the way I
played it it was it was working like a
charm okay went here maybe I should take
that but I don't don't don't think so
yeah Brooke be too and this was this is
a bad idea I mean Quincy 8 is really bad
what didn't I take the pawn actually now
I really should do that there's no
reason not to because there's no I'm not
cut not cut off now and winning in the
pawn is quite good it's not just the
pawn it also is a it's a nice important
pawn for the structure okay probably I
should do that the whole thing here I'm
really in trouble and if he if he would
have played Bishop c4 I'm even in more
trouble yeah this is stuck plus plus one
according to the engine yeah it's
terrible and this was in comparison
worse but still still excellent for wine
yeah I just have a choice between many
beds and bed lines and it was good what
you body plate okay rookie 6 is nice
some pretty standard but strong
yeah I'm just toast yeah I cannot he
just is winning here not nothing more
nothing less yeah I have to take be too
quite clearly have to take this pawn
yeah okay not good at the moment thanks
for watching